[Music]
the newest Dune is one of the best uses
of that like the Hollywood budget I feel
like it's one of the films that in a
long time I feel that really takes
advantage of having a bajillion dollars
it's it's almost like those movies
require those kinds of budgets so like
like it's hard for an Avengers end game
and this is not like a smart observation
but it can't exist without like you know
50 million or 250 million dollars or
whatever but a lot of that is just
paying people to like animate the
characters like doing whatever whereas
Dune I feel like they take all this
money and they're using it to like build
a world and I think that's why I say
like the earlier superhero movies that's
kind of what that budget was meant for
but the later ones it just feels like
it's kind of like anime like what you're
saying like a lot of the budget just
goes to like them fighting most people
like man it's easy it's straightforward
yeah it's good stuff yeah I mean punch
punch I can't lie when when Thanos came
out I'm like this fucker's mean kind of
I thought he looks so [ __ ] stupid
yeah giant grape yeah with a big chin
bald can you imagine they put hair on
him look at look up cartoon long stringy
blonde hair there you go damn it you
can't even get like oh let me get like
Yu-Gi-Oh here let me get actual Thanos
that one below looks pretty good A
little yeah there you go see there you
go yeah see like they should give him
the cap they should have gave him the
cap I agree with that but I feel like
this is one of the better
fake you're like or one of the better
like that's the mix around it's like
they're they did the best they could
with this yeah because Jack Kirby or who
whatever
985 year old man was like he's a guy
from space yeah you Stan Lee's like
listen readers each guy he's going to
stop people from the The Avengers and
he's going to fight Spider-Man yeah
who's 15 years old yeah it's like he's
like he's purple like Stan I need more
he's big and he's purple and he's from
space did I tell you that I've been 104
for my entire life I've never looked
younger than 104 years old and he's only
purple because when [ __ ] Stan these
dudes made this show they only had like
seven colors yeah exactly uh we haven't
used purple yet I really don't like that
color [ __ ] it let's just use it and even
the Infinity Stones are all the other
colors they had yeah they're just like
maybe that'll help balance it out a
little bit Yeah dearest readers yeah I
love doing Stan late in you know I'm
[ __ ] what I really wish they would do
is like a dark X-Men film and use
sentinel and give us like a [ __ ]
actual I mean they did do a pretty good
job with him in the like recent films
but I'd love to see like a scary ass
Sentinel like in 3D like with modern
tech yeah after I've just [ __ ] on
superhero movies for five minutes oh you
can still open it's like I think there's
a difference between like [ __ ] on a
movie and just being like it doesn't
inspire me yeah I can go to a Marvel
movie and slap my belly and clap and
feel things but it's not like I go home
and I'm like you know what
that's the thing that I needed that's
the missing link